Fox's first primetime series, Married…with
Children, remains notable for both its risqué
jokes and abrupt cancellation—as well as
delivering the fledgling FOX network a ratings
hit.
Have you wondered what the members of the
lovably low-class Bundy clan have been up
to since they went off the air?
Here's what they're working on now.
Ed O'Neill
Since finding fame as curmudgeonly shoe salesman
Al Bundy, Ed O’Neill has had a pretty steady
career.
That isn't to say he hasn't suffered through
a few dry spells, though.
O'Neill starred in a number of short-lived,
obscure projects after Married… with Children.
Remember John from Cincinnati, Big Apple,
or the 2003 relaunch of Dragnet?
We don’t either.
Things turned around in 2009, when he landed
the role of Jay Pritchett on ABC's award-winning
Modern Family.
Aside from moving him into a higher tax bracket
in both his personal and fictional lives,
this also means O'Neill gets paid to pretend
Sofia Vergara is his wife—a job most guys
would do for free.
O'Neill has also found the time to earn a
black belt in Brazilian jiu jitsu—not bad
for a guy who recently turned 70.
Katey Sagal
After ditching Peg Bundy's giant red helmet
of hair, Sagal has worked pretty consistently.
In addition to a long-running gig as the voice
of Leela on Matt Groening's animated Futurama,
Sagal starred in 8 Simple Rules.
She then went on to score a role on a little
show about a group of motorcycle enthusiasts
called Sons of Anarchy.
Sagal's work as the vicious Anarchy matriarch
Gemma Teller Morrow was a far cry from her
days as Peg; instead of scarfing down bonbons,
she proved she was just as good at kicking
butt and taking names.
Of course, the fact that she's Anarchy creator
Kurt Sutter's wife didn't hurt her chances
of nabbing the part, but she definitely made
the most of the opportunity.
Sagal took home a Golden Globe and a Prism
Award for the role, and she only had to kill
a few people to get there.
Christina Applegate
As lovable blonde bombshell Kelly Bundy, Applegate
was a fan favorite, but finding another hit
series hasn’t been easy.
Her first starring sitcom role in NBC's Jesse
lasted only two seasons, and her next TV project,
ABC's Samantha Who?, was canceled after two
seasons as well.
Her third shot at post-Married sitcom hit,
Up All Night, was also off the air after,
you guessed it, two seasons.
She's continued to work in film, co-starring
in hits like The Sweetest Thing and the Anchorman
movies, but it hasn't improved her television
luck.
All that professional turmoil is nothing compared
to the personal battle she faced in 1998,
when Applegate discovered she had breast cancer.
Luckily, it was found in its early stages,
and after a double mastectomy, she emerged
cancer free.
David Faustino
Bud Bundy proved to be the height of David
Faustino's acting career.
While he's worked consistently, most of his
gigs have been one-off appearances, like his
appearance in Entourage where he plays himself.
On the other hand, his voice acting career
has been more prosperous.
He's lent his vocal talents to popular kid-focused
series like Winx Club and The Legend
of Korra.
But the best thing about Faustino's post-Married…with
Children life, aside from shedding that glorious
mullet, is his ability to stay out of trouble.
Unlike many former child actors, Faustino
hasn't amassed a collection of mug shots.
He does have one arrest for marijuana possession
in 2007, according to Fox News, but other
than that, Faustino's been an angel.
Maybe some of that good karma will pay off
and his rumored Married…with Children spinoff
series will be a hit, unlike previous spin-off
attempts.
Amanda Bearse
If it seems like Amanda Bearse, who played
Bundy neighbor Marcy Rhoades-D'arcy, disappeared
from the TV, it's because she pretty much
has.
Since 2001, she's only appeared in front of
the camera only seven times.
However, her directing career's taken off.
She's lent her camera talents to programs
like Dharma & Greg, MADtv, and the Rosie O'Donnell-produced
The Big Gay Sketch Show.
Off the set, Bearse revealed some real-life
animosity between her and her television adversary
Ed O'Neill.
When she wed Carrie Schenken in 2010, O'Neill
didn't get an invite because Bearse feared
he'd laugh during the ceremony.
After teasing her about her chicken legs for
over a decade, what'd he expect?
Ted McGinley
Known as much for his role on The Love Boat
as his work playing male bimbo Jefferson D'Arcy,
Ted McGinley has worked consistently since
1997 without landing anything permanent.
His most prominent role came courtesy of Hope
& Faith, which catapulted Kelly Ripa's career...and
no one else's.
In fact, many consider McGinley's series presence
so lackluster that he's been accused of carrying
the “McGinley Curse,” which claims that
adding him to a show guarantees its cancellation.
McGinley counters that accusation by pointing
out that many of the shows he's appeared on
lasted for several seasons after he came aboard.
We see your point, McGinley… but please,
don’t audition for Game of Thrones.
David Garrison
Since gaining fame as Steve Rhodes, David
Garrison has continued to work in television
from time to time, post-Married…with Children.
Garrison's made dozens of one-off appearances
on shows like Arliss, The West Wing, and The
Good Wife.
However, his first love has always been the
theater, to which he returned—and it's a
good thing he did.
In addition to appearing in Broadway productions
of Bells Are Ringing and The Visit, Garrison
was part of the original cast of the hit Wicked,
in which he played the Wizard of Oz… and
a very weird, off-Broadway Hannibal Lecter.
Michael the dog
Known to most as Buck, the Bundys' self-preserving
Briard, Michael retired in 1995.
As true fans know, Buck was replaced by Lucky,
the Cocker Spaniel possessed by Buck's reincarnated
spirit.
Sadly, Michael actually died less than a year
after his final appearance in 1996, so he
didn't get to enjoy retirement for very long.
Michael was 92 in dog years when he passed.
Even though that's only 13 in human years,
it wouldn't be an exaggeration to say he had
a fuller life than most of us ever will...
Thanks for watching!
Subscribe to our YouTube channel to watch
more videos like the one you just saw.
And leave us a comment to let us know which
TV show casts you’d like to catch up with...